This podcast is brought to you by Worst Bird. Hallo, hallo. Hallo, ihr Lieben. So, wir brauchen ein paar Regeln. Wir brauchen ab jetzt ein paar Regeln für die Intros. Okay, Florentin? Ich habe das Gefühl, du schneidest auch mittlerweile alles einfach rein. Glaub mir, ich würde gerne andere Intros auswählen, aber die Auswahl ist mittlerweile so knapp. Dieses Projekt steht und fällt mit euch. Sonst müssen wir uns das Prager Filmorchester mieten und denen selber was schreiben. Das ist nämlich jetzt, also ihr seid angezählt. Das ist Nummer eins. Das ist der erste Tadel. So, meine Regel Nummer eins ist, für die nächsten Intros unsere Stimme weglassen. Wir reden danach sehr lange, das ist die Idee des Podcasts.
Wir haben wirklich, ihr tut uns keinen Gefallen, wenn ihr vor allem schon so in Intros Sachen sagt wie Hallo, unsere Namen, so uns fehlt dann wirklich gute drei Minuten, die wir einfach brauchen. Ja, Regel Nummer zwei, keine Garageband-Loops.
Regel Nummer drei, und das ist ein Ausrufezeichen dran, denkt an die neuen Zuhörer. Was denken die denn? Niemand denkt an die neuen Zuhörer, ja. Die Armen. Denkt an die neuen ZuhörerInnen, weil jetzt kommt nämlich da jetzt das Ding und die neuen Menschen denken, was? Ich denke, das ist ein Podcast über Ufos. Mein Arbeitskollege hat mir diesen Podcast empfohlen, aha, merkwürdiges Gehen. Wir reden schon unerkenntlich reden wir schon für das Teil des Podcasts. Für den unbedarften Hörer ist auch nicht ersichtlich, wann das Intro aufhört und wann wir anfangen. Das könnte jetzt auch noch Teil des Intros sein. Jetzt kommt nochmal Worseburn, dann geht's los. Ganz schwierig. Also, ja, von Coco kommt diese Woche das Intro. Dankeschön, Coco. Coco ist der Schüler, der dafür sorgt, dass die ganze Klasse nachsitzen muss. Und ab jetzt hagelt es hier Verweise, ab jetzt geht es hier wirklich los. Ihr seid angezählt, die Warnung wurde ausgesprochen. Die Warnung wurde ausgesprochen.
Mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will. Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO. Ich kann dich kurz vorstellen, du bist Stefan Tietze, du bist Bestsellerautor, Lebemann und inoffizieller Bürgermeister von Tietzstadt. Und du bist Florentin Will, ein gesuchter Straftäter, Child-Molester und eigentlich dürfen wir uns auf 100 Meter, auch komisch, dass das die Regel ist, nicht sehen. Zum Glück hat der Phantomzeichner bei meinem Wanted-Bild so schlechte Arbeit geleistet und hat mich so verhunzt, dass ich selber auch nochmal angeklopft habe und gesagt habe, das ist doch nicht euer Ernst. Wo sind denn die Ohren? Wo sind denn die Ohren? Und da mache ich die Augen zu. Da mache ich selbst auf meinem Phantombild die Augen zu. Nein, die sind offen. Das ist doch nicht offen. Gucken Sie, ein bisschen Schlitz ist noch da. Ein bisschen ist noch da. Und da mache ich rote Augen. Wie sind Foto, ein schlechtes Foto. Waren Sie meine Augen zu und da mache ich rote oder rote Augen, selbst bei den Phantombildern. Ja, ganz schlecht getroffen auf jeden Fall und von daher bin ich glaube ich sicher und ich bin aktuell auf der Flucht. Ich lebe von Autobahnraststätte zu Autobahnraststätte, immer wenn... Wie? Wie? Naja, immer wenn die Polizei ankommt, fahre ich weiter. Mit welchem Spritgeld? Das Spritgeld wird knapp, da bin ich sehr ehrlich, das Sprit wird knapp, aber ich habe jetzt gedacht, man kann ja auch Rapsöl einsetzen, habe meinen Tank mit Raps vollgestopft, an einem schönen gelben Feld stehen geblieben, mit Raps vollgestopft. Wie lange hat es gedauert, bis du so aus Raps so eine Tankladung voll Öl bekommen hast? Boah, sagen wir mal, das hat schon gute zehn Minuten gedauert und dann wieder schöner auf die A1. Und ich sage dir, innerhalb von drei Sekunden komplettes Chaos. Komplettes Chaos, der Innenraum war voller gelber Blüten, ich habe kaum noch was gesehen. Und frittiert. Frittiert, Lüftung, alles gelb, überall reingezogen, herrlicher Rapsgeruch. Herrlich, ne? Wir lieben alle diese... Wir lieben alle lieben Raps. Diese leichte Rapsnote, die glaube ich jeder kennt,
die dann so in der Luft ist. Und der hält sich ja, der Geruch. Also der hält sich.
Der ist immer noch drin. Auf der A1
riecht man den noch ein bisschen aus nach Ruhig.
Das ist echt so ein Ding. Du hast so
einen gestechenen Gelbton. Es ist so wie so
ein Real-Life-Filter. Alles ist gelb. Ich finde
Raps toll. Ich bin jetzt auch
tatsächlich über die Autobahn gesaust
und habe rings und lechts die Rapsfelder gesehen und bewundert. Und es ist schon schön. Da fängt für mich auch dann der Sommer an, mit diesem knallegelben Rapsfelder. Waren die immer so gelb oder war das ein Marketingding? Oder hat man die aufgedreht, den Gelbton? Ich glaube, die haben nochmal wirklich hochgedreht in der Züchtung. Weil, also ich glaube, das ist, also denkt man so, erst mal auf der einen Seite Öl, tote Dinosaurier über Jahrtausende zusammengepresst, kaputt, machen die Welt kaputt, riesige Qualmschwaden und auf der anderen Seite wunderschöne gelbe Blumen als Alternative. Das kann doch nicht so, da muss doch irgendeine findige Marketingfirma dahinter gesessen haben und gesagt hat, wir nehmen die schönste Blume und machen sie zur Alternative des hässlichsten Flüssigkeit. Wie zeigen wir den Menschen, dass sie lieber Rapsöl nehmen sollten als Erdöl? Lassen Sie das maximal schön machen. Wir sind ein bisschen Pfeil. Wir planen jetzt den Kohleausstieg und als Alternative verbrennen wir Zimtsterne. Und ist jemand gegen Zimtsterne? Nee. Man kann Zimtsterne verbrennen zur Energiegewinnung? Ja, klar. Und die ganze Erde riecht so schön zimtig. Herrlich. Zimt ist immer toll. Weihnachtsbäckerei. Zimt macht alles besser. Ich glaube auch, dass man Kohle einfach mit Zimt bestreuen könnte. Und wir hätten diese ganze leidige Diskussion von wegen Kohleausstieg, von wegen was ist Kohle überhaupt,, von wegen, kann man das anzünden, von wegen, mir erklär mir immer wirklich kurz, wie Kohle funktioniert, ohne Scheiss, wie Kohle funktioniert, von wegen, du sagst immer Kohlenstoff, Kohlenstoff, was ist denn bitte das erstmal, erklär mir das erstmal, also diese ganze ewige Diskussion, die in tausenden Talkshows ausgeführt wird, nervt mich und deswegen, vielleicht würde es helfen, da ein bisschen zum Traum zu reden. Aber jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, weil um halt Experimente mit Öl und bla bla bla zu machen, hast du ja schon einen PhD in Physics, in Biologie, in bla bla bla. Die sind ja extrem weit. Und manchmal sagt man ja, der Blick eines Kindes hilft ja auch nochmal irgendwie für einen Perspektivwechsel.
Manchmal kommen Kinder auf ganz kreative Lösungen. Der Blick eines Kindes hilft manchmal für Perspektivwechsel. Das ist das Sprichwort. Das ist vielleicht nicht ganz das Sprichwort, ich kriege es nicht mehr ganz zusammen. Aber manchmal ist so eine Outside Perspective vielleicht super interessant, um auf Dinge zu kommen, auf die andere und auch Leute, die es zumindest wieder so betriebsblind. Und wir, vielleicht, können der Wissenschaft noch ein paar Sachen mit auf den Weg geben. Zum Beispiel, versucht mal, ein bisschen Zimt in den Tank zu machen. Ja, also du sagst ... Weil das haben die ja noch nicht ausprobiert, weil die denken, Zimt in den Tank, seid ihr komplett bescheuert. Ja. Und wir sagen, ne, versuch's doch erst mal. Ja. Also du sagst, Steffi, sieben Jahre, wird für einen Tag Chef der grössten deutschen Ölraffinerie und kann einfach mal machen. Kann einfach mal machen. Steffi wird Chefin von BP. Ja, okay. Wir setzen die alleine, damit sie auch nicht abgelenkt wird, auf diese Erdin-Ölinsel. Auf die Insel, ins Cockpit? Mitten vor Norwegen, Stavanger, bumm. Okay. Alle anderen gehen aufs Boot, fahren weg. Fahren weg. Steffi allein auf der Ölinsel. Steffi allein auf der Ölinsel. Steffi allein auf der Ölinsel hat zwei Kohleleit, ein Kamerateam, was sie nicht ansprechen kann, weil die nicht antworten werden, die sind vorher instruiert. Ja. Die haben sich Spiegelanzüge an vielleicht. Die haben Spiegelanzüge an. Dass die sich dann immer selber sieht. Das ist gut. Ich glaube, das verwirrt Steffi Ultra. Und dann kommt sie gar nicht alles auf die Idee. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst, dass das dann das Experiment wird, aber okay. Und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert. Es können ja zwei Experten gleichzeitig sein. Einmal, wie wird die Ölraffinerieindustrie revolutioniert, andererseits, wie reagieren kleine Kinder auf verspiegelte Menschen. Genau, das ist zweigeteiltigt. Kannst du ja 70-30-Experimente. Dann teilt man sich auch die ganzen Kosten auf die Reise. Perfekt, wunderbar. Wenn es ja spannend zu werden soll. Steffi kommt auf die Arbeit, sieben Uhr. Dann hat sie sehr viele Fässer vor sich stehen. Ja, Zimt. Wachs mal Stifte. Ah, Vanilleeis. Vanilleeis, Raps. Ja. Und so weiter. Und dann kann sie das mal einfach in die grossen, ja jetzt weiß ich nicht wie eine Ölbauinsel genau funktioniert, aber da wird es ja irgendwo einen Kessel geben. Ich gehe mal davon aus. Da wird ja irgendwo so ein Silo sein, wo man das hat. Natürlich, so ein Turm. So ein Pressturm.
Und sie darf man machen.
Ja, so.
Okay.
Nee, aber ganz im Ernst, warum, die Wissenschaft ist festgefahren.
Ist sie das?
Du sagst das jede Woche, so selbstbewusst, denn immer wieder sagst du, ja, die Industrie hat sich ja in der Sackgasse manövriert. Ich habe das Gefühl, da ist immer nicht so wahnsinnig viel dahinter, wenn du das sagst. Ist jetzt nur meine Intuition. Das ist meine Intuition. Das ist meine leidigen Rückfragen. Auf die habe ich auch keine Lust mehr. Also, du sagst, die Industrie ist in ein tiefes, tiefes Loch gefallen. Ja. Wer wirft ein Seil? Ja, so. Und das ist nicht an uns. Ja, Kinder war ja für mich eher so eine Metapher. Es braucht Leute mit so einem Blick von außen einfach mal, mit einem Outside the Box denken. Und dann ist es eine neue Phase. Willst du in die Ölraffinerie einsteigen? Willst du eingeladen werden von Bob P., dem Chef von BP, der sagt, Stefan T., wir brauchen dich? Ja, jetzt nicht unbedingt nur Öl. Generell überall, glaube ich, können wir mit unseren pfiffigen Gedanken, was ist zum Beispiel, kriegt man nicht eine bessere Impfung hin, wenn man Zimt zumischt? Ist sie da nicht noch wirksamer? Kann es sein, dass viele deiner Lösungsvorschläge einfach nur Zimt bereiten? Oder, keine Ahnung, zum Beispiel Photovoltaik. Ja. Hat das schon den perfekten Energieumsatz? Oder hält es nicht, wenn man da ein bisschen Zimt drüber streut? Wir können es testen, wir können es ausprobieren, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt. Wir hätten aber ein Riesenproblem tatsächlich, wir sind da komplett in eine Sackgasse manövriert, wir haben uns da selber eingemauert quasi.
Ich habe es gesagt, ich habe es proktosiziert.
Also wirklich sorry, wir versuchen das seit Jahren vor der Öffentlichkeit zu verstecken, aber wir sind ganz, ganz, wir stehen auf einem Glatteis.
Wir stehen auf einem spiegelgeladen Glatteis, wir wissen nicht, in welche Richtung.
Wenn wir versuchen, uns zu bewegen, stürzen wir hin. Das Eis ist glatt und dünn. Dünn ist glattes Eis mit sehr vielen Kühen auf dem Eis. Richtig. Ja, völlig richtig. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt noch zu oft hinfallen, stürzen sowohl wir als auch die Kühe ins Eis. Das ist die aktuelle Situation. Deswegen vielen Dank, Herr Tietze, dass Sie gekommen sind. Und zwar, wir bräuchten Hilfe. Flugverkehr ist ein Riesenproblem, liegt brach. Wir brauchen die Revolution. Flugverkehr, passen Sie auf. Weil es ist ja, vor allem, wir reden ja hier auch über das Problem des Treibstoffs. Zu viel Zwei-Emissionen. Ja, die Besteuerung Besteuerung ist natürlich Schneiden in die Gewinnereien. Kerosin, wir brauchen Zimt. Wir brauchen, und jetzt muss man sich diese Chernobyl-Szene vorstellen, wo er sagt, Bohr und Sand. Wie viel? 80 Tonnen. So, jetzt muss man sich mich vorstellen, wie ich irgendwo auf so einem Hochhaus stehe, er würde uns den Himmel angucken, weil wir da näher an Flugzeugen sind, weiß ich nicht, und der fragt, was brauchen wir, und ich sage, Zimt. Und du fragst, wie viel? 80.000 Tonnen. Okay, ich besorge ihn. Alles klar. Gut, okay. Der Zimthändler.
Stefan Tietze rettet die Flugindustrie.
Danke, Tietze.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Wir wissen es wirklich nicht.
Das weiss es albern, aber wir wissen es nicht.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Aber vielleicht wissen wir es eines Tages.
Alles, was ich weiss, ist, ich werde in die Zimthindustrie investieren.
In AG Zimth, Zimth oder was auch immer.
Fände ich einen guten Trend. Zimth, Cineminis. Alle investieren, in AG Zimt, Zimt oder was auch immer. Fände ich einen guten Zimt-Trend.
Zimt in den Cine-Minis.
Alle investieren in irgendwelche Meme-Bitcoins und du in Zimt.
Tatsächlich, als ich früh als Kind mit dem Konzept der Aktie in Berührung kam,
hat mein Vater mir erzählt, ja, mein Bruder, also dein Onkel,
also der Bruder deines Vaters, also der da, der hat Zuckeraktien, weil die Leute werden immer Zucker brauchen. Und deine Augen wurden ganz gross und dein Magen knurrt. Das ist ja genial, weil es stimmt. Es stimmt. Du wirst ja in Zukunft nicht deinen Kaffee trinken wollen ohne Zucker.
Das ist ja, wenn du da einmal angewöhnt bist, willst... Ich trinke schwarz und mit Zimt. Riese Zimt. Gut, aber wenn du dir jetzt dazwischen mal eine Flasche Sprite gönnst, dann ist da ja auch einiges an Zucker drin. Nicht zu knapp. Das stimmt, da ist eine Menge Zucker drin. Und ich dachte genial, bis ich natürlich gehört habe, dass es Tausende von Süßstoffen und Zuckerersatzmitteln gibt. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie der aktuelle Zuckerkurs steht. Aber das fand ich schon immer eine gute Idee, in das zu investieren, was man immer brauchen wird. Aber ist das die perfideste Art der Welt, Kinder an den Finanzmarkt heranzuführen? Ja, mein Taschengeld habe ich komplett investiert in Südzucker. Das ist wie einem Kind zu sagen, du kannst in Zucker investieren, ist wie einem Hund zu sagen, du kannst in Knochen investieren. Oder der Maus zu sagen, du kannst in Käse investieren. Oder einem Bären zu sagen, du kannst in Honig investieren. Oder einem Pferd zu sagen, du kannst in Karotten investieren. Oder einem Wal zu sagen, du kannst in Plankton investieren. Oder Stefan Tietze zu sagen, du kannst in irgendwelche dummen neuen Startups investieren. Okay, oder Flo und den Wild zu sagen, dass er in fucking Warcraft 3 investieren kann. Aber auf jeden Fall, ich weiß nicht, wie der Zuckerkurs steht gerade. Ich glaube, da ist natürlich viel auch im Grossen Zuckerkrieg verloren gegangen, in der Grossen Zuckerschmelze, als irgendwo eine Atombombe eingeschlagen ist. Top fünf albernste Kriege. Oh, okay, endlich. Endlich, Platz fünf der Skateboardkrieg, als das US-amerikanische Militär dachte, sie können die Kriegsführung umstellen, revolutionieren, indem alle Soldaten Skateboards kriegen und die dann einfach nur noch Backflips gemacht haben die ganze Zeit und Ollis. Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Busselballkrieg, der war einfach nur cool. Ja, der war richtig cool. Unglaublich gefährlich. Der war super cool. Manchmal mit coolem Krieg dann gefährlich im Sinne von tödlich oder... Weiß ich nicht. Ja, okay. Aber das war, das war albern. Platz vier, uncoolster Krieg. Ich war kurz davor, den Straußenkrieg zu erwähnen. Nein. Aber der war cool. Der war cool. Der war richtig cool. Dann würde ich sagen, dieser Krieg, wo alle plötzlich dachten, nee, falsche Jäger, das ist albern, wir sind schon weiter und sich diese Flughörnchen-Anzüge angezogen haben, womit man aber nicht so gut zielen kann, deswegen sind sie immer noch vorbeigerast. Und sie mussten immer wieder hochklettern, immer wieder Hubschrauber und dann wieder runterfliegen und wieder verpasst. War zu lang, am Ende waren alle ziemlich kaputt, groggy und haben sich nie getroffen, deswegen war es sehr uncool. Platz Nummer drei, der erste Unterwasserkrieg der Menschheitsgeschichte, haben sich alle Beteiligten wesentlich, wesentlich cooler vorgestellt.
Und schneller vorgestellt.
Man stellt sich raus, unter Wasser ist man wahnsinnig langsam, es ist super anstrengend, du musst alle Minute wieder hochtauchen und Luft holen. Aber die haben auch leider die normalen Waffen genommen.
Die Kugeln flogen langsam, prallten ab.
Und du bist halt einfach aus dem Weg und musst dann immer wieder. Und die Armeen haben sich eigentlich nur gesehen über Wasser, wie sie ... und wieder untergetaucht sind. Also das war eine komplette Katastrophe. Tatsächlich auch der Erste Krieg ohne Verluste. Keine einzige Tote, sondern alle haben gesagt, dass es doch Bullshitshit. Im Gegenteil, zwei Kinder wurden geboren unter Wasser.
Das stimmt, ja, das kam unerwartet. Unter Wasser geboren. Platz Nummer zwei, Weltraumkrieg. Ja, und das stellt man sich immer so cool vor durch Filme wie Star Wars, Star Trek, Avengers, Battle Star Galactica. Battle Star Galactica oder aber auch Guardians of the Galaxy zum Beispiel. So, aber jetzt muss man sich in der Realität vorstellen, du hast keinen Sound und Krieg ist auch 50% Sound. Ja, 50% Sounddesign, ja. 50% Sounddesign ist Krieg. Ja. Du hast nichts und es passiert auch nicht so viel. Du kannst auch nicht so viel machen, du hast keine Flammen, weil warum sollten im Weltall Flammen sein? Ja. Das macht keinen Sinn, da ist keine Luft. Im Grunde ist es eine Schneeballschlacht. Es ist alles wahnsinnig kalt im All. Man sieht auch nichts, es ist stockfinster. Das passiert nicht. Da stellt man sich immer vor, dass man ein Raumschiff sähe. Aber das ist kein Licht, das ist nichts. Von daher. Du kannst dir eine Lampe anmachen, oder nicht? Ja. Aber man sieht sich ja selber immer, oder? Sieht man sich im Weltall selber? Ich glaube nicht, ist es doch finster.
Hat man nicht so einen Bonus, dass man sich selber schon sehen kann? Oder irgendwie sowas gab es doch.
Nee, jetzt kannst du in den Einstellungen einklicken.
Ach so.
Was für eine POV du hast. Also kannst du POV, kannst du auch Third Person.
Wie geil das wäre. Real Life Third Person, Overshoulder Perspektive?
Würdest du Over the Shoulder machen?
Ja, aber sofort.
Ich würde es lassen, wie es ist.
Warum? Weil es immer mein Ding ist. Ich lasse es so, wie ich mich am Anfang an das Spiel gewöhnt habe. Nee, ich würde sofort, dass die Kamera so hinter, über mir ist, so ein bisschen so ein bisschen Ryan Gosling-mässig. Bullshit. Immer so hinter dir herfährt. Ja, aber dann steuerst du dich zur Küche mit BASD. Ja. So, dann stehst du an der Küche. Dann siehst du ja nicht, was deine Hände machen. Ja, aber ich weiss doch, was meine Hände machen. Ach so. Also die Steuerung ist noch gleich. Die Steuerung ist gleich, du siehst es nur so leicht von oben angeschrägt, oben nach unten. Also du siehst vor dir die Tomate und du schneidest sie, aber du siehst halt auch direkt, was links von dir ist. Falls jemand sich von hinten an dich ranschleicht, siehst du sofort. Ich glaube, es ist ganz cool. Und vor allem glaube ich, zum Autofahren ist es ideal, weil du siehst halt
alles um dich rum. Ja, das stimmt.
Und diese grossen SUVs wird immer mal los,
weil alle eh von oben gucken können. Ja.
Vogelperspektive gar nicht, so direkt
oben drauf, so auf den Scheitel
oben drauf, so altes
Zelda-mässig, das auf gar keinen Fall.
Siehst du gar nichts? Das ist albern.
Und Ben Third-Personal noch ziemlich nah an mir
dran. Ja, das wäre gut. Einfach mal ein Reboot, Leben zwei, einfach mal das zweite Leben. Man sieht sich ja umgekehrt, also deine Augen sehen ja was anderes, dein Gehirn werdet das Signal ja quasi um. Sagst du. Das ist ja ein Thunderbolt-Kabel, das dreht das ja um, weißt du, dass du sagst, die Wissenschaft. Sagst du. Die sind aber auch so seit Jahren, stecken die in der Zwickmühle. Aber ist schon das wirklich, ich habe das auch mal gehört, dass dann die Kinder alles falsch rumsehen, deswegen sagen die immer, lass mich hoch oder halt irgendwie solche Sachen, wo alles falsch rum ist. Deswegen sagen die immer, ganz kurz, bevor ich jetzt nochmal anfange zu schreien. Kommt mal alle hoch, bitte. Kommt mal alle zusammen. Ähm, ich sehe alles verkehrt herum. Nicht spiegelverkehrt, ich sehe einfach alles um ...
Wirklich? Ich will jetzt nochmal anfangen zu schreien. Kommt mal alle hoch, bitte. Kommt mal alle zusammen. Ich sehe alles verkehrt herum, nicht spiegelverkehrt, ich sehe einfach alles um 180 Grad gedreht. Nein, das kann nicht sein. Warte, lass mal, dann geben die einfach einmal so einen Klaps auf den Hinterkopf und dann zack, switcht es um. Nee, deswegen ist ja, wenn man sich, dann gibt es das Experiment, was man aber nie nachmachen sollte.
Mit den Brillen, ne?
Nein, das, wo man sich rückwärts... Das war cooler als das, was du jetzt sagst.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Dass man sich rückwärts ... ... auf die Couch setzt. Ja, definitiv cooler. Und dann guckt man verkehrt rum auf die Welt und irgendwann dreht das Gehirn das Signal wieder um und du siehst wieder richtig rum. Obwohl du verkehrt rum im Moment ... Das ist verrückt, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ich mir auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Was ich gehört habe, ist mit den Brillen, dass Leute coole Brillen aufbekommen haben, so mit Leopardenmuster und rot und grün, teilweise ein Glas rot und das andere grün ist. Und die waren durch die Bank selbstbewusster und erfolgreicher, hatten einfach ein besseres Leben gefühlt, weil sie witzige Brillen auf hatten. Total cool eigentlich. Und ich mir auch dachte, wäre die Menschheit besser, wenn einfach jeder eine Brille tragen, eine witzige Brille. Halt, wo dann so Shrek-Ohren noch an der Brille dran sind oder so. Ja, oder so Kätzchenohren nach oben hin. Oder mit so einer Kette oder halt die Motherfucking-Werner-Herzog-Brille, die in der Mitte den Magneten hat und die man so auseinandernehmen kann. Oh yes. Das ist das aller coolste. Oh yes. In a minute, Werner Herzog, wo ist deine Brille, ich will sie. Das wäre so cool. Mega. Nein, aber das Brillenexperiment war, dass man Leuten Brillen aufgesetzt hat, die die Sicht umgedreht haben. Ja. Und nach einer gewissen Zeit, die mussten es ständig tragen, durchgehen, also sie haben alles auf Falschum gesehen irgendwann switcht das Gehirn und dann, wenn sie die Brille wieder abgenommen haben, waren sie auch in der normalen Sicht falsch rum. Und mussten dann erst wieder, stell dir mir vor, wie fucking gruselig das ist. Du nimmst irgendwann die Brille ab und siehst die ganze Welt falsch rum, ohne dass du irgendwas auf dem Kopf hast und denkst dir, ist das jetzt immer so? Aber wie ist dieser Switch, ist das wirklich schlagartig oder dreht sich das so ganz langsam? So wie die David Letterman-Show. Du siehst doch, wenn du versuchst, ein Bild bei Mac zu drehen oder sowas, eben diese lächelige Vorschau, sorry für alle Windows-User jetzt, aber dann dreht man es ja erstmal falsch rum. Ja, natürlich. Das Bild erstmal falsch rum. Sieht man auch dann die Männchen in seinem Kopf, wie die so langsam das Bild erst mal falsch rumdrehen. Erst mal Spiegeln drehen und wieder zurück. Und dann zu merken, nee. Warte mal, eine Drehung ist 190 Grad. Nee, nee. Man stimmte mal vor, die Drehung ist so langsam um. Und auch so, dass man die Ränder sieht. Genau, von 16 zu 9, dass dann so schwarze Stellen entstehen. Weil wir sehen ja, ich würde ja behaupten, wir sehen ja weiter von links nach rechts als oben unten, ne? Sagst du. Hör auf, das immer zu sagen. Du hast doch auch eine Meinung. Guck mal jetzt kurz, guck mal kurz. Okay, ich gucke mal kurz. Achte mal auf dein Blickfeld. Würdest du sagen, links rechts ist mehr als oben unten? Ja, Spanne. Naja, wenn ich die Augen ganz weit aufmache. Ich glaube, es kommt darauf an, wie weit offen die Augen sind. Ich behaupte, du hast von links nach rechts mehr. Aber warum sollte man? Weil du links und rechts Augen hast. Der Augeapfel ist eine Kugel, die ist doch in alle Richtungen gleich. Ja, aber das ist ja links und rechts ein Auge, das ist ja nicht oben und unten ein Auge. Versteht ihr? Das macht schon Sinn. Ach so. Dass man mehr von links nach rechts gucken kann. Okay. Deswegen meine ich aber, wenn die das drehen, die Männchen in dem Kopf, dann hast du ja kurz links und rechts schwarz. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Das muss fucking scary sein. Also da hätte ich keine Lust drauf. Also falls ihr daran denkt, mich für so ein Brillenexperiment anzufragen, bitte streicht mich von der Liste. Auch die Welt auch Das wissen wir nicht, kann mich nicht ausschliessen. Streicht mich bitte von der Liste, nehmt meine Adresse darunter und lasst es einfach. Ja, ich hätte da auch Angst vor, auf jeden Fall. Aber ich meine, das kann der Kopf. Der Kopf kann Dinge einfach so verwerten. Und dann ist es ja auch nicht mehr weit weg zu Third Person. Ja, das stimmt schon. Weil, was ist, wenn dir so
eine Idee, du setzt
dir eine VR-Brille auf
und hast eine GoPro auf dem Kopf. Oh ja.
Das ist genau das, was wir gerade beschrieben haben.
Wie lange musst du das tragen,
bis der Kopf
das umschaltet? Und du die Brille
abnimmst und es trotzdem noch so siehst?
Das ist ja
abgefahren. Oder
andere Frage. Oder wir
beide setzen uns jeweils Brillen
Vielen Dank. abnimmst und es trotzdem noch so siehst. Das ist ja abgefahren. Oder andere Frage. Oder wir beide setzen uns jeweils Brillen auf, in den Brillen sind Kameras und ich sehe, was du siehst. Und du siehst, was ich sehe. Wir sind ein fucking Avatar jetzt. Und irgendwann stehe ich dich und du mich. Und dann kämpfen wir gegen die Navi. Aber können wir das dann einen Tag lang machen und wenn wir dann die Brillen wieder abnehmen, sehen wir auch, was der andere sieht? Wie krass wäre das denn? Ja, dann sind wir connected. Dann sind wir so eine Person. Dann haben sich unsere Neuronen zusammengeballert. Aber ist das eine Show, das grosse Promi-Tandem? Zwei Promis kriegen Brillen auf und sehen, was der andere sieht und müssen einen Tag bestreiten und müssen sich gegenseitig helfen? Oder müssen gegeneinander spielen? So, weil wenn sie sich helfen ist ja lame, dann stehen sie immer direkt nebeneinander und dann ist es ja auch nicht so viel anders. Übrigens haben wir uns die ganze Zeit aufs falsche Pferd gesetzt. Wir haben auf den falschen Moderator gesetzt. Wir haben auf Guido Kanz gesetzt. Ja, ich bin immer noch bei Guido Kanz. Ich nicht, denn herausgestellt hat sich Folgendes, Steven Gäthchen hat die Podcast-Ufahusaufgabe gemacht und Moloch untergebracht. Oder er hat einfach nur einen immens grossen Wortschatz. Wäre ihm auch zuzutrauen. Würde ich Steven Gäthchen auf jeden Fall zutrauen. Würde ich auch zutrauen, jedenfalls. Falls du das hörst, Steven. Wir brauchen dich für sechs verschiedene Shows. Du musst jetzt doch mal alle Folgen hören. Ja. Und schreib dir mal, schreib mal mit. Times Up. Wir haben so ein paar verschiedene Showformate mal irgendwann. Ja. Die kriegen wir jetzt auch so nicht mehr zusammen. Nee, aber ich hatte noch vorhin die Idee, dass große Promis schlafen. Sechs Promis auf der Bühne liegen in sechs Betten und der Promi, der als erstes einschläft, gewinnt eine Million Dollar. Ich hätte behauptet, dass ich überall einschlafen kann. Kannst du nicht. Live-Publikum vor der Kamera. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich nicht leicht. Und die sind dann angeschlossen, ihre Finger haben so eine Klemme und dann der Computer sieht, wann man
schläft oder nicht, das ist ja wahrscheinlich
relativ simpel darzustellen, wenn man so das Gehirn
sich anguckt, und
sobald einer schläft, blinkt das Licht auf
in einem grellen Orange
und dann sagt Stephen Gäthchen,
ah, jetzt ist hier jemand eingeschlafen
und das ganze Publikum sagt,
schlafi, schlaf, schlaf, schlaf, Und der Promi wacht auf, Applaus, Applaus, Applaus. Ja, eine Mädel ist eingeschlafen und muss jetzt singen. Und das Problem an der Show ist halt, dass man im Vorhinein nicht weiß, wie lang sie ist. Ja, so und was passiert während der Show, das das ist meine Frage an Sie. Ja, also die Sache ist erstmal die, die Show kann halt Stunden, Stunden dauern, wenn wirklich niemand einschlafen kann, kann aber auch noch fünf Minuten vorbei sein. Und alle Promis, die an der Show beteiligt sind, sind damit beschäftigt, nichts zu tun, um einzuschlafen. Korrekt, korrekt. Jeder kriegt einen witzigen Pyjama, und dann machen wir so einen Auftritt von wegen, ah, du hast den Pyjama. Das trägt eine Minute. Eine Minute pro Promi. Das trägt sechs Minuten. Ja, dann haben wir doch schon mal fast die erste Werbeunterbrechung. Das ist doch das, worauf ihr geldgierigen Produzenten auch seid, oder? Ja, okay, drehen Sie den Spieß um. Geschickt. Also, jeder Promi hat einen Auftritt, du hast dann verschiedene Leute, alle haben irgendwie einen witzigen Pyjama an. Ja, das haben sie bereits gesagt. Können dann der Eisbär Pyjama und so. Ja, okay, weg von weniger Pyjama. Man kann da ja, mein Gott, man kann da ja so ein bisschen modelmäßig auch machen, dass die so einen Laufsteg runterlaufen. So ein Laufsteg aus Kissen, dann gibt es die große Kissenschlacht, genau, die große Promi-Kissenschlacht. Um damit die nochmal richtig aufgedreht sind vom Einschlafen? Drei gegen drei, dann kriegt jeder noch Süssigkeiten-Buffet, damit die so richtig aufgedreht sind. Kaffee, viel Kaffee. Kaffee, damit die so richtig on edge sind. Kaffee, noch eine Folge Pink Panther, dann lachen die sich kaputt. Ich dachte, die Show wäre eher verschiedene Räume, sechs verschiedene Räume, das Publikum, so ein dasartiges, riesiges Publikum, mit so einem Steil, können alle Schlafsäle gucken. To Kill Bill mässig. Genau, und die sind da alle drin, die Promis, und die haben verschiedene Taktiken, um einzuschlafen. Die einen hören drei Fragezeichen, das wird recht nicht schwierig. Nee, sehe ich gar nicht. Was sehen Sie? Weil die Promis müssen ja interagieren. Die Promis müssen ja miteinander interagieren.
Sich wach halten.
Entweder sich gegenseitig wach halten.
Genau, und dann hast du nämlich so einen, ja, dann heißt ja, oh, Christoph Maria Herbst hat, oh, ich habe hier Läuse dabei.
Die tue ich ins Bett von Carolin Kebekus.
Und Carolin Kebekus sagt, ich habe hier eine Tarantel dabei, die werfe ich ins Bett von Jürgen, von Klaus, von Klaus Wovereit oder was auch immer. Ja, tot. Und guter Schläfer. Und dann kommen die alle zusammen und machen alle ihre Tricks. Und der Moderator Steven G. merkt schon nach zehn Minuten, da wird heute niemand mehr schlafen. Die sind so aufgedreht, die sind so wild. Wohlgegen das Publikum. Der eine springt auf dem Bett herum, der andere ist immer noch bei der Kissenschlacht. Die sind alle richtig aufgedreht, sechs aufgedrehte Promis. Und ja, und Stephen Gältchen hat so einen Blick. Man sieht nur Stephen Gältchen, der so ein, oh, das wird eine lange Nacht. Man sieht vor allem Stephen Gältchen mit Mühe. Genau. Stephen Gältchen hat langsam mit der Mülligkeit zu kämpfen und sagt, gib mir auch mal einen Espresso bitte. Und trotzdem kämpfen die Lieder mit der Schwerkraft und irgendwann liegt er da nieder. Und gewinnt die Show. Stellt sich raus, Steven Gädchen kann das am besten. Ja, das ist mal ein Twist. Kennt man gar nicht aus einer Show. Oder wer aus dem Publikum als, genau, Publikum gegen Promis.
Ja, ich glaube, bei der Show ist die Chance sehr groß, dass aus dem Publikum eher jemand einschläft, ehrlich gesagt. Jeder aus dem Publikum hat auch so eine Klemme am Finger. Und falls aus dem Publikum jemand einschläft, gewinnt der automatisch, gewinnt der fünf Minuten für einen Promi seiner Wahl. Bitte? Gewinnt der Wahl? Er gewinnt fünf Minuten für einen Promi seiner Wahl.. Dann sagt er, ah, Rita aus Gerritsried ist eingeschlafen. Rita, Rita, Rita ist wach. Mir gefällt verschiedene Aufweg-Methoden auch. Einmal diese Tröte, so ins Gesicht rein. Ja, Rita, Rita, wachen Sie auf. Sie sind eingeschlafen. Wo bin ich?
Sie sind in der Show Schlafmütze.
Oh Gott, ich sage das für ein furchtbarer Traum.
Sie sind eingeschlafen, jetzt dürfen Sie sich einen Promi aussuchen, der fünf Minuten
auf die Uhr oben drauf bekommt.
Ja, hier, Klaus Wobereit.
Alles klar, fünf Minuten für Klaus Wobereit!
So, was heißt das konkret?
Der kriegt jetzt fünf Minuten auf die Uhr oben drauf. Und wenn Karolin Kebekus jetzt fünf Minuten eher einschläft, ist es gleich stark. Nein, nein, nein. Was? Er hat fünf Minuten auf der Uhr und Was ist für die Uhr? Er hat das erst mal. Er hat das erst mal. Er kann ja selber überlegen, was er damit macht. Er wird einfach fünf Minuten auf die Uhr. Was ist denn die Uhrzeit der fünführers? Fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins. Genau, das ist so eine große Sanduhr wegen Sandmann. Sandmann ist der Sidekick. Sandmann ist der Sidekick. Simon Gose-Johann oder sowas als der Sandmann. Und du hast so eine riesige Sanduhr. Und immer wenn einer fünf Minuten gewinnt, dann kriegt er in seine Sanduhr Sand für, also Sand für fünf Minuten geschüttet, kommt dann von oben so runter, so ein Rieselstrom, rieselt das dann auf und dann sagt er fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins und dann hat Bovareit fünf Minuten mehr in seiner Sanduhr. Das ist auch gut, das Sandthema ist auch nett. Das Sandthema ist nett, ja, das Sandthema ist generell nett. Aber währenddessen, während wir hier unsere ganzen Shows pitchen, seit Jahren, macht Kristall jetzt die grosse Murmelshow auf RTL. Verdammt nochmal. Ja, der ist gut, er ist einer der besten. Bei jedem Pitch-Meeting sehen wir Kristall und denken uns, verdammt nochmal, wie können wir mitreffen? Der kommt immer vor uns aus dem Büro mit so einem breiten Grinsen im Gesicht. So einem gewinnenden Lächeln. Und dann kommen wir rein. Follow this. Und dann kommen wir rein mit unseren Props immer. Riesige Sanduhr. Er immer, er hat nichts. Hi. Du musst hier rein. Du arbeitest hier, deine Arbeit geht theoretisch vor. Okay. Sorry. Wie mit unseren Riesen-Props, immer so Riesen-Karteikarten. Du hast so ein riesiges Bett dabei, ich eine riesige Sanduhr und ganz viel Karteikarten. Er hat nichts. Er kommt einfach gewinnend, lächelnd aus dem Raum. Oder schnippt uns so eine Murmel zu. Viel Spaß da drin, Jungs. Ne, Euro. Steckt uns einen 50-Euro-Schein in die Tasche. Viel Spaß da drin, Jungs. Viel Spaß da drin, Jungs. Ich krieg das hin. Ich glaub an euch, diesmal wird's was. Oh, und dann geht er wieder rein, weil das auch eine gute Show ist. Diesmal wird's was. Ja, was ist die Murmelshow? Ich weiss nicht, die Murmelbahn. Murmelbahn. Also jeder wählt sich eine Murmel aus, dann rollen die eine Bahn runter und wer gewinnt hat, gewonnen. Ich stelle mir das vor wie die Murmel-Olympiade, die es immer gab bei YouTube, die ich teilweise so viel geschaut habe. Oh toll. Wo ich auch kurz dachte, jetzt habe ich komplett die Kontrolle über mein Leben verloren. Das ist super, vor allem das Publikum sind auch Murmeln. Das ist so genial. Ja, die haben auch gerufen. Also aber auch mit, und dann gab es die Orangers, das waren die Orangenen, dann haben die immer, oh, es war so viel Liebe im Teil.
Also nur zur Erklärung, da hatte jemand eine Menge Murmeln, hat die den Berg runterrollen lassen und hat daraus ein komplettes Sport-Event gemacht, also mit Einbändungen und mit Publikum, eine komplette Tribüne, aber die Tribüne war besetzt natürlich auch mit Murmeln. Und so kleine Schildern und so. Und dann gab es verschiedene Teams, die verschiedenen Farben der Murmeln. Und irgendwann gab es auch immer mehr Disziplin, Weitsprung, dann gab es so ein Hindernisparcours. Dann, es gab verschiedene Disziplinen. Es war tatsächlich damals, ich glaube, das war so 2017 oder so, stand wirklich kurzzeitig die Frage offen, ob nicht der Menschensport vollständig ersetzt werden sollte durch Murmelsport. Weil Murmeln waren beliebter als Menschen, Murmelnwettrennen war beliebter als Menschenwettrennen und die. In so einem ganz schmalen Fenster, Juni 2017 waren kurz Murmeln beliebter als Menschen. Aber das Olympische Komitee hat sich zusammengesetzt und hat gesagt, Jungs, Mädels, wie schaut's aus, unsere Zuschauerzahlen sinken, wir brauchen neue Leute, wollen wir nicht auf Murmeln umsteigen. Ja, aber auch weil die Murmeln in diesem Komitee unterrepräsentiert waren, hat man sich dann dafür entschieden, es einfach zu lassen. Und das herrschende System setzt sich weiter fort, vielleicht zu Unrecht. Hätten die mehr Murmeln in ihrem Gremium gehabt, sie hatten einen Haufen Früchte dabei, weil sie damals schon gedacht haben, Fruit Ninja und so, jetzt kommt die Früchtezeit. Fruit Loops, Fruity Juice, Juicy Fruit. So, das Wettrennen, also welche, du hast so einen Hügel, welches Obst rollt am schnellsten runter, gewinnt die Kiwi, gewinnt die Melone, da haben die Leute geschrien und gejault und gejauchzt, ist dann aber relativ schnell wieder in Vergessenheit geraten. So, und da hat man sich für Murmel entschieden, also das ist wirklich eine fantastische Idee. Da war irgendwer, hat sich einfach gedacht, ich mache jetzt eine riesen, riesen Olympiade über Murmeln. Und das waren ganz viele Videos gibt es da, die immer so 20 Minuten lang sind. Und ich habe die irgendwann mal alle geschaut, wo ich dann auch kurz dachte, jetzt drehst du durch. Ja. Weil ich war da so unterhalten von. Ja, es ist spannend. Es braucht nicht viel.
Es ist spannend, es braucht nicht viel.
Und Steven Spielberg sagt so, Alter, davon fühlst du so unterhalten von. Es braucht nicht viel. Es ist spannend, es braucht nicht viel. Steven Spielberg sagt so, Alter,
davon fühlt sich unterhalten.
Wisst ihr, wie lange ich an diesem Film geschrieben,
gedreht und geschnitten habe,
wie viel Geld das gekostet hat?
Nee, aber das ist ganz geil, weil die Gelbe,
die rollt halt erst einmal relativ weit hinten
und dann am Ende rollt sie da vorbei.
Dinosaurier erwachen zum Leben,
Leben. Die Murmeln haben kleine Schilder. Wir haben ein tausendköpfiges Team. Das macht ein Student allein in seiner Kack-Studenten-Bude. Ah, guck mal, die eine hat die andere aus der Bahn rausgekickt. Oh, echt? Das ist cool. Du musst verstehen, die Rote hat ja beim letzten Mal gewonnen und jetzt wurde die rausgetreten aus der Bahn, so als ob der irgendwie sich rächen wollte oder so. Total witzig, weil es ja einfach nur Murmeln sind, aber das wird immer so witzig kommentieren. Einmal tatsächlich war eine Murmel verletzt. Oh, da ist ein bisschen was rausgesprungen, Glas rausgesprungen. Oh fuck. Woher kommt der Murmelsport? Ich glaube, das ist, langfristig hat sich das entwickelt aus dem Kugelsport im Allgemeinen, Bull Bowling und man irgendwann einfach. Bull Bowling Botcher. Bull Bowling Botcher, die drei grossen Bs der Kugelsport. Das ist ja kein Zufall, dass Ball mit B anfängt und Bull Bowling Botcher Baseball. Also das wäre ein epochaler Zufall, wenn das wirklich ein Zufall sein würde. Und die haben, oder auch bei Billard zum Beispiel, auch Billard, auch da hat man irgendwann gemerkt, es funktioniert besser ohne Menschen. Wenn die Kugeln einfach ihr Ding machen und es funktioniert besser. Von daher, so ist das glaube ich entstanden und im Grunde eigentlich so eine massive Kugel hat irgendwie immer was, das ist so was mächtiges, so eine wirklich dichte, schwere Kugel, Boccia, aber jetzt auch so Bowling, das ist so, ah. Wir haben jetzt seit nur mehr anderthalb Jahren, Pitchen wir bestimmt jede Woche eine Show. So, jetzt mal komplett ohne Spaß, ganz kurz. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass gar nicht so viele Leute von Tele5 zuhören. Habe ich auch. Aber jetzt habe ich mal ganz kurz einen Vorschlag, eine wirkliche Frage, warum es das in Deutschland nicht gibt, wo ich dich jetzt bitten würde, dass wir einfach zusammen zusagen, jetzt schon mal präventiv. Okay, also es ist gar kein Pitch, sondern du erkundigst dich nur. Es gibt eine Show überall in jedem Land, die heißt Robo Wars, wo Roboter gegeneinander kämpfen.
In dem Ingenieurland Deutschland, wo getüftelt wird, wo gebastelt wird. Warum haben wir kein eigenes Robo Wars? Ferngesteuerte kleine Roboter, die auf unterschiedliche Art den Gegner ausschalten müssen. Es geht darum, du baust Killer-Roboter, die sich in einem Turniersystem, du hast verschiedene Teams, die haben alle einen Roboter, die haben Namen, die sind süss, die haben Persönlichkeiten, die haben andere Waffen und die Idee ist es einfach, andere Roboter umzubringen. Und in unserem Fern, Deutschland liebt doch ferngesteuerte Dinge, Modellflugzeuge, whatever, warum bauen wir nicht in verschiedenen Teams Roboter,
lassen sie untereinander antreten, wir beide kommentieren
das, wir machen das
und dann spreche ich jetzt mit euch,
RTL, zwei.
Oder drei, je nachdem.
Oder drei, oder ZDF
Neo, wir machen das, wir brauchen
so eine Halle, geht auch jetzt gerade super,
brauchen so eine Halle, verschiedene Teams mit verschiedenen Robotern, die verschiedene Roboter bauen, wir begleiten die Teams mit der Kamera, beim Bau der Roboter und bei den Ideen, so Tüftler-Teams und wir beide kommentieren das mit Frank Buschmann noch, schön. Vielleicht ist das echt ein Sicherheitsding, dass du das in Deutschland nicht so einfach machen kannst, weil da musst du TÜV und alles hier und dann hast du da halt so freistehende, rotierende Klingen und halt so eine kleine Guillotine auf Rollen. Ich glaube, hier ist es Roboterquälerei. Oh, das kann auch sein. Ich glaube, der Roboter hat hier zu viel gemacht. Er hat zu viel Rechte schon. Er ist im Bundestag vertreten, im Gremium. Da ist dann diesen Roboter mit dieser rotierenden Serie geplant. Ich habe seit Jahren gesagt, dass Angela Merkel ein Roboter ist, habe ich seit Jahren gesagt. Aber ich würde da auch gerne, das ist auch, glaube ich, ein cooles Setting für eine Serie. So Robo Wars, vor allem, ich denke mir jedes Mal, wenn dann, weil da gibt es ja dann so verschiedene Gimmicks, da gibt es den Flammenwerfer, die Müllpresse und manche Es gibt verschiedene Roboter. Genau, ja und manche wollen ja gar nicht direkt kämpfen, sondern den anderen nur reindrücken in die Stacheln oder so. Genau, es gibt ja am Rand dann immer noch verschiedene Hindernisse und so. Genau, und ich stelle mir jedes Mal vor, wenn dann irgendwie der Super-Sägeblatt-Roboter besiegt wird von dem kleinen Flinken, der dort rücken will, geht er nach dem Kampf hin und sagt, der eigentliche Kampf findet gleich auf dem Parkplatz statt. Okay, Robo Wars ohne Kameras, Kameras aus nur du und ich und unsere Roboter. Da hast du keine Pressen und Flammenwerfer an. Ja, da musst du dich selber behaupten, mano y mano, los geht's und dann auf dem Parkplatz, glaube ich, nach der Sendung. Schraubo y Schraubo. Nach der Sendung bildet sich von den eingeweihten Zuschauern nochmal ein Kreis und dann geht's richtig los. So brennende Mülltonnen und so Fässer. Das ist die eigentliche Sendung, das ist der eigentliche Kampf. Davor, das ist nur Show, Gladiatorenkampf. Nee, ich will danach die Gasse den Parkplatz haben, ich will die Streetfights, ich will die Streetfighter. In unserem Robo-Wars packen wir aber auch mal einen Hund gegen so einen Roboter. Ja, absolut. Einen Hund, gerne mal eine Tarantel oder einen grossen Hirschkäfer oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Oder eine Katze, du kannst auch Katzen abtrainieren, abrichten, das wäre richtig gut. Oder, Kleinkinder, so eine Katze mit so einem Flammenwerfer auf dem Kopf. Und eine GoPro, damit man auch mal hinschneiden kann. Oder halt wirklich dann, der Endboss ist ein Delfin. Delfin? Und dann musst du halt gucken, wie du deinen Roboter baust, dass er auch gegen den Delfin ertreten kann. Nee, weil wir machen gleich. Florentin und ich würden uns hier anbieten, für einen ganz normalen Etat würden wir die Robo Wars Germany kommentieren. Wie viel Geld brauchen sie? Ganz normal. Ein ganz normales, stinknormaler etat. Branchenübliches Etat. So, und wir kommentieren das und wir können es auch produzieren. Wir haben ja hier eine Produitionsfilme, die Bild- und Tonfabrik. Zusammen machen wir RoboWars Germany und wir begleiten die Teams beim Bauen, beim Ingenieur, Rumingenieuren ihrer kleinen Roboter. Da gab es auch einen, ich war ein Riesenfan von Yeti, ein cooler Roboter in der amerikanischen Version. Es gibt ja verschiedene, es gibt ja die Umwerfen, die Flipper, die haben einfach nur so eine kleine... Finde ich immer lame. Sind lame? Auch wenn krass ist, wie viel Kraft die in dem kleinen Ding drin haben manchmal. Die reden einfach nur den anderen um und machen den manövierumfähig. Dann gibt es zwei Flammenwerfer, einen Flex, dann gibt es Zang und Heber, Leute, die andere Roboter hochheben können. Und ich glaube, wir sind in einem perfekten Land dafür. Eigentlich müsste es hier perfekte Leute dafür geben. Man kann natürlich auch einen Spin-Off machen in der Luft. Ich sehe zwei Drohnen, die gegeneinander kämpfen, mit Stacheln, mit einem Flammenwerfer in der Luft. Ist die Musik Bayblade weitergedacht? Eigentlich schon. Das finde ich schon ganz geil, dass du dann einfach sagst, okay, jetzt Air Combat, jetzt geht's richtig los, Drohnenflug, musst du überlegen, willst du eher so... Das ist Staffel zwei, Robo Wars The Elements. Ja, aber ich meine, ich glaube, wahrscheinlich würde jeder eine Drohne einfach mit einem Laserschwert dran machen und dann halt durch die Gegend fliegen. Aber würde ich mir auch anschauen. Weil ich fände geil, Robo Wars und weil das ist ein bisschen lame, weil es immer das Gleiche ist, gleiche Arena immer, immer die gleichen Gegner. Wir machen das dann, Folge zwei ist dann auf dem anderen Terrain, also auf Wasser. Ja. Da müssen die dann schwimmende Roboter bauen. Oh ja, oder auf Magma. Auf dann, genau, die Elements.
Das zweite ist dann Magma, Lava oder das andere, was es auch immer ist, wenn es an der Oberfläche noch flüssig ist.
Dann in der Luft, Drohnen, die Kinder kämpfen und Unterwasser.
Das ist schon nicht schlecht, aber gibt es dann auch verschiedene Teilnehmer für die Elemente oder muss jeder Roboter in allen vier Elementen bestehen können? Oder gibt es dann das Erdteam, das Wasserteam, die haben dann so blaue Roben an. Misty. Misty fürs Wasserteam. Okay, also da wird es dann schon ein bisschen komplizierter. Und Pokémon. Es wird komplizierter und Pokémon. Weil du hast dann, also eine Show ist dann nur Wasser oder ist in jeder Show vier Elemente vertreten?
Ich würde sagen, du hast acht Teams, die jeweils gegeneinander antreten. Und in der ersten Show ist das Element Erde, da wird auf der Erde gekämpft. Die zweite Show ist das Element Wasser, da müssen die neue Roboter bauen. Die haben immer eine Woche Zeit, wie Let's Dance, die haben eine Woche Zeit für neue Roboter. Alles klar, okay. Und Feuer ist, wir fahren alle nach Sizilien zum Ätna und suchen erstmal einen aktiven Vulkan und dann läuft da die Lava runter, alle rennen schreiend weg, nur wir nicht, unser Kamerateam, immer noch komplett verspiegelt, setzt sich hin und legt die Roboter auf, die Lava, die sofort schmelzen, Sendung vorbei. Sendung vorbei. Okay, ja klingt gut. Also ich würde sagen, dafür können wir einen stinknormalen, branchengängigen Etat freigeben. Ich würde da wirklich nicht drüber gehen. Null. Null Cent drüber, gebt mir den Durchschnittsbudget aller Produktionen, die wir je gemacht haben und gebt den raus. An diesen Herrn hier. Nicht wirklich, weil, und das werden wir jetzt am Ende wieder ein bisschen Quatsch erzählt, aber ich will wirklich Robo-Warschermit kommentieren. Du willst diesen Pitch noch retten, habe ich das Gefühl. Ich will diesen Pitch noch retten, den du uns sicherlich gezogen hast, durch Lava gezogen hast. Aber mach den Pitch so, als gäbe es die Sendung noch nicht. Ich habe eine geniale Idee. Das wird sie umhauen.
Kampf der Roboter.
Mit so einem Roboter-Prop unterm Arm, wenn sie das Büro laufen.
Aber geht auch Knete?
Nein.
Was?
Kann ich auch einen Roboter aus Knete bauen?
Klar, du kannst es aus allen Materialien bauen.
Weil dann können wir so einen Crossover machen zwischen Robo-Wars und dieser Knet-Wrestling-Show.
Die habe ich nicht verstanden.
Habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Was ist die Knet? Celebrity-ity Deathmatch, wo Knet-Promis gegeneinander kämpfen? Auf MTV früher? Kenne ich nicht. Kennst du hundertprozentig. Knet-Männchen gegeneinander kämpfen? Ja, Knet-Promis kämpfen gegeneinander in Celebrity Deathmatch. Superbrutal und wurde auch kommentiert. Knet-Promis. Also kämpft man dieses Jahr, wo Murmeln kurz erfolgreicher waren als Menschen und Knet-Promis als Murmeln. Ich finde, Knete hat eh stark an Charme verloren. Eingebüsst. Hat es eingebüsst in den letzten Jahren. Der wahre Verlierer dieses Jahrzehnts ist Knete eigentlich. Ja. Ich habe am Anfang des Jahrzehnts... Die grössten Verlierer des Jahrzehnts küren wir hiermit. Mit so einer Ziele.... Auf Platz 10 bis 1 überall Knete. Blaue Knete, gelbe Knete, rote Knete, braune Knete. Am Ende wird eh alles braune Knete, weil man es eh alles zusammenmischt. Aber auch wirklich, ich finde es so geil, weil die Knete hat sich entwickelt. Ich habe das ja ein bisschen mitverfolgen können. Ich habe ja meinen Zivildienst mit Kindern gemacht und hatte natürlich dann sehr viel. Kinder haben viel mit Knete zu tun, ich habe mit Kindern zu tun, also habe ich viel mit Knete zu tun.
Es war ein konstanter, es war so ein Lebenselixier, Knete war immer da, immer da, egal wo du hingehst, immer Knete im Haar, Knete am Pulli, Knete ist omnipräsent. Und wenn man heutzutage in den Kindergarten geht, nicht mehr mehr Kinder da. Ja, eben, wo sind die hin? Und bei diesen Knetherstellern war ja irgendwann das Problem, dass Knete halt fucking giftig war und die Kinder halt sofort gegessen haben und gestorben sind. Hunderte, tausend Kinder gestorben. Hundert Millionen Kinder. Und die Knetindustrie hat gesagt, da müssen wir was dagegen kneten, das müssen wir umkneten nochmal unser Produkt. Und dann war das... Ist deren ganze Fabrik auch aus Knete eigentlich? Das ist diese grosse Plastikdrückfabrik, wo man so die Formen drücken kann. Die in groß ist die Play-Doh-Fabrik. Du brauchst einen neuen Stuhl für mein Büro. Ich sehe nur, die Knet-Fabrik auf der einen Seite kommen diese bunten Töpfchen raus und auf der anderen Seite gehen so ganz merkwürdige Sachen rein. So ein Elefant, ausgemusterter Zirkuselefant, so ganz viele Zeitschriften, drei Menschen werden so reingefahren auf einem Fließband, irgendwie ganz viel Kleber und hinten kommen einfach Knete raus. Und irgendwann haben die gesagt, nein, unser Knete muss schon essbar sein, die muss schon essbar sein, die darf halt nicht gut schmecken. Aber irgendwann hat sich diese Entwicklung so weit fortgesetzt, dass mittlerweile die Knete die Kinder fast schon motiviert, die zu essen. Das steht wirklich ganz groß drauf. Bedenkenlos essbar. Überhaupt kein Problem. Ja, ja. Weil wahrscheinlich viele Eltern Panik hatten, stirbt mein Kind, wenn ich dann Knete mache, ah, nicht ein Rätsel. Ja, und so träumende Supermarkteinräumer, die wahrscheinlich auch eher in Richtung Kühlregal stellen, als Spielabteilung, weil zu groß essbar draufsteht, weil das so das Kaufargument wurde.
Und irgendwann, ich glaube, die Entwicklung wird sich so weit fortsetzen, dass irgendwann Knete einfach als normales Nahrungsmittel auch angesehen wird, weil Kinder sagen, ich würde gern Knete zum Frühstück haben. Und da sieht man auch mal, wie perfide diese Spielzeugindustrie ist, denn wurde abgelöst durch Kinetic Sand, dieser kinetische Sand.
Ich kann mit dem nichts anfangen.
Doch, ich schon.
Nee, aber der Hating, da kannst du doch nichts draus bauen.
Da kann man was draus bauen, doch, doch, doch.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020 Durch Kinetic Sand. Dieser kinetische Sand. Ich kann mit dem nichts anfangen. Doch, ich schon. Da kannst du doch nichts draus bauen. Da kann man was draus bauen. Doch, doch, doch, doch. Mit Brezel aus Kinetic Sand, das will ich sehen. Doch, doch, doch, doch. Da kannst du mit draus bauen. Nein, die Brezel aus Kinetic Sand? Ich kann Brezel aus Kinetic Sand machen. Wirklich. Und das Ding ist aber, was lustig ist, Kinetic Sand hat Knete abgelöst, ist aber nicht essbar. Jetzt hat man was Neues ein Substitut entwickelt. Jetzt muss die Knetindustrie gucken, wie sie ihr Produkt weiter vermarktet, ob man nicht sagt, man geht jetzt komplett in die Essensrichtung. Und jetzt Hot Take? Ich glaube, das sind die gleichen Fabriken. Die gleichen schwarz qualmenden Fabriken machen Gnetic Sand. Imkreis von 20 Kilometern, in dem man wohnen darf, wegen Gesundheitsbelastung. Welche Art von Gesundheitsbelastung? Gehen Sie lieber mal einen Schritt zurück, im Ernst, im Ernst, gehen Sie wirklich lieber mal einen Schritt zurück gerade. Aber stell dir mal vor, so eine süße Knetfabrik hat so riesige Schornsteine, einfach schwarzer, molochartiger Qualm raus. Und alle Arbeiter so harte Sicherheitsanzüge, so richtig dick mit so Schleusen.
Und schwarze Gesichter, weil so verqualmte Gesichter und offensichtliche Lungenprobleme, Hustenblut.
Einer steht offensichtlich in Flammen, aber das Produkt ist Knete.
Alles für die Knete.
Aber ich könnte es mir schon vorstellen, weil ich sag mal so, ich habe ja oft mit Knete zu tun gehabt und du willst es schon weg snacken. Das sieht halt schon lecker aus. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wenn die wirklich jetzt sagen, wisst ihr was, Knete, vergesst mal den Knetspaß, ihr esst es jetzt einfach bitte. In verschiedenen Geschmacksrichtungen, Bubblegum, Kirsch, Pfefferminz, würde ich jetzt erstmal so die ersten drei machen,
und die mit den Farben zusammenhängen, und dann können die Kinder auch die zusammenkneten,
wie sie es zusammen mischen möchten.
Du hast dann einmal die Schokoknete, die Kirschknete, können die zusammenkneten. Da hast du die ganze Zeit mit deinen Händen die rumgeknetet.
Und dann isst du das noch, uch.
Kinder sind auch so eklig.
Widerlich.
Mit ihnen eh schon dreckigen Händen, Pfoten, kneten die die ganze Zeit da rum und essen das dann auch noch. Aber keine schlechte Idee, also wie gesagt, Play-Doh und oder RTL Nitro, falls ihr zuhört, wir haben gute Ideen. Ich habe das Gefühl, dieser Podcast ist ein Ideenloch, ist einfach so ein schwarzes Loch der Ideen. Die Ideen kommen unten raus, oder sind einfach alle scheiße, das kann auch sein. Ist dann auch schlecht, oder irgendwann wird irgendein italienischer Fernsehproduzent, die das ganze Podcast-Igob finden, so eine Festplatte, nachdem hier das Studio in die Luft geflogen ist und unser Projekt vergessen ist. Und dann kommt auch dem Sender Ragazzi, kommen dann die ganzen Ideen. Kommen all unsere Ideen und Buongiorno Steven Gettian, Steven Gettiano, Stefano Gettiano, der muss sich umbenennen. Stefano Gettiano. Herr Gettian, wir haben so viele Anfragen an Sie aus Italien, aus Bella Italia. Wollen Sie nicht in Italien? So, der vorigene Time-Supp. Time-Supp? Haben die gerade Time-Supp kommentiert? Aber Steven Gettian spricht aber kein Italienisch, sondern moderiert auf Deutsch und wird einfach untertitelt die ganze Zeit. Wird einfach knallhart undtitelt. Fände ich aber gut. Aber apropos gute Fabriken, ich muss immer noch überlachen, ich habe ja häufig bei meiner Mom in der Firma in den Ferien gearbeitet, habe da im Einkauf gearbeitet, im Labor gearbeitet. Und gegenüber von denen ist eine Schweizer Firma, hat da ihre so Riesenfabrik und die stellen Aromen her. Das ist eine Aromenfirma. Wow. Givaudin heißen die. Das ist eine Schweizer einfach und es riecht halt, das ganze Industriegebiet riecht immer, weil die so riesen Schornsteine haben, riecht halt immer nach dem, was sie gerade machen. Und die machen halt Aromen, also Geruchsaromen und Geschmacksaromen, ballern die halt einfach raus, stellen die her. Aber welche Konsistenz haben die? Ist es Pulver oder Flüssigkeit? Also was da in der Luft liegt, ist knallhart gasförmig. Jedenfalls Weihnachten riecht es da häufig nach Spekulatius und Zimt und so. Man denkt, jetzt ist Weihnachten, warum macht der das denn jetzt erst? Weil das ist doch in drei Monaten wahrscheinlich als erst so eine Marktreife, keine Ahnung. Aber es kann halt auch mal vorkommen, dass die irgendwie Knoblauch oder sowas herstellen, so Aromen für Chips oder so einen Scheiss. Und dann ist halt das ganze Industriebeet, kannst du einfach nicht das Fenster aufmachen. Ah, das ist ja geil. Weil es halt unglaublich doll stinkt. Und haben die auch so einen Werksverkauf oder so, wo man so einen ein Kilo Beutel Kirscharoma sich holen kann? Ja, da waren immer so Sommerfeste von deinem Firma und meiner Mom. Und ich wollte immer nicht da in die Fabrik gehen, sondern immer rühr. Was machen die? Wie sieht es bei denen aus? Das ist ja genial. Das ist so Geschmack in Reinform. Die machen einfach geballten Geschmack. Aber das frage ich mich ohnehin, ob Fabriken immer alle Produkte parallel produzieren oder nacheinander.
Du hast gerade gesagt, die gesamte Fabrik produziert Banane für zwei Tage und dann produziert die gesamte Fabrik Orange. Das ist ja schon abgefahren. Das müsste dann alle Maschinen nochmal durchwaschen. Ich glaube, die wollen auch die Firmen in der Umgebung jetzt nicht quasi im Stichwort
braune Knete. Ja, ja, ja.
Alle Gerüche zusammen ergeben, nämlich braunen
Kackgeruch. Vor allem alle Gerüche zusammen
riechen nach Douglas. Immer nach Douglas.
Ich glaube wirklich, Douglas ist genau der Geruch,
wenn du alle Parfüms der Welt zusammen mischt,
hast du genau den Douglas-Geruch. Genau.
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn die den auch verkaufen würden.
Die sind Douglas alle
Parfüms zusammengemischt Geruch.
Ja, sag ich auch nicht.
Aber das ist ja schon abgefahren.
Vor allem, was auch da, ich würde mich gerne interessieren, was geht da links in die Fabrik rein?
Also ist das alles synthetisch, chemisch oder ist im Knoblauchmonat kommen dann wirklich zentnerweise, tonnenweise Zehner angerollt oder nicht?
Vor allem, ich fände es auch gut, wenn zum Spekulatius-Aroma müssen die Spekulatius verarbeiten. Wir drücken aus Spekulatius drücken die Aromen aus. Ein pfiffiger Mitarbeiter hat die Frage, Moment, aber woher kommt das Spekulatius-Aroma in den Spekulatius? Ja, von uns, vom letzten Jahr. Aber woher kommt das? Von Spekulatius. Ja, aber das muss ja schon das Aroma haben von uns. Ja, vom letzten Jahr. Ja, aber woher hat das aus dem letzten Jahr das Aroma? Von uns! Aber wo haben wir das denn dann her? Von den Spekulatius! Wenn von uns das Spekulatius-Aroma kommt, woher kommt dann das Spekulatius-Aroma, was wir erhalten? Von den Spekulatius. Es ist nicht so schwer. Aber die kommen noch von uns. Es ist ein ewiger Kreislauf. Niemand isst Spekulatius. Kein einziges Spekulatius wird gegessen. Es wird alles wiederverarbeitet. Es ist ein ewiger, riesiger Kreislauf. It's the circle of Spekulatius. Live! Beschwindwindelig. Mal alle Fabriken sehen, ey, das ist schon echt. Aber ist das nicht die Idee von Galileo? Von der Sendung Galileo? Ja, ich glaube, die fragen auch viele Fabriken an, aber halt nicht alle sagen ja, weil die müssen ja nicht ja sagen. Also ich glaube, es gibt halt, ich glaube, du siehst vor allem Fabriken von innen, die direkt Produkte herstellen, die man kaufen kann, weil die wollen ja Werbung machen. Das ist ja eine Art von Werbung. Wenn Galileo in die Hanuta-Fabrik eingeladen wird, denken sich alle, boah, 10.000 Hanuta, wenn ich nur eins davon haben könnte. Und dann holen sie einen Hanuta. Aber du gehst ja jetzt nicht in eine Dichtungsringfirma, weil die ja keine Werbung brauchen. So, und dann warum sollen die da irgendwie Jumbo Reinhardt reinlassen, dass der da irgendwie Dichtungsringe vom Fließband nimmt, wenn die da nichts davon haben? Ja, das stimmt schon. Und ich glaube, es sagen auch nur die Fabriken zu, die, naja, ich glaube auch die Dichtungsringfirma würde sich freuen über die Aufmerksamkeit. Aber ich glaube, es sagen nur die Fabriken zu, die nichts zu verstecken haben. Weil ich glaube, Spekulatzer Roma hat was zu versprechen. Ich glaube, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich glaube, die leckersten Dinge werden in Fabriken erstellt, die was zu verbergen haben. Aber hallo, was zu verbergen haben. Aber hallo. Dann kommt das Kamerateam irgendwie dann kommt an bei Twix und dann so piep, piep, piep. So, hier sind die Fledermäuse, müssen wir mal unterschreiben.
Was?
Haben sie sich verfahren wohl?
Nee, wie jede Woche.
Was, Quatsch? Nein, tun sie die Kamera
weg. Und da, glaube ich, kann man
die richtigen Geheimnisse herausfinden.
Das stimmt schon, ja.
Ja, Fabriken, auch so,
was mich interessieren würde, wären...
Was ist das in Jaffa Cake innen drin? Dieses Gelee, was ist das? Fledermaus in Reihen. Wahrscheinlich, oder? Das ist einfach so gestampfte Fledermaus. In Reihen mit Spekulatius-Aroma. Oder was ist in Erfrischungsstäbchen drin? Was ist diese reine Essenz? Freshness. Ich glaube wirklich, für ein Erfrischungsstäbchen müssen 60 Flederbose in so einen Mixer rein. Ich mag die nicht mal. Und dann ganz tropft unten einzeln so die Tröpfchen von diesem Erfrischungsstäbchen Saft raus. Ich mag die nicht mal. Aber der Name lässt mich immer wieder denken, ich mag das total gern. Aber wie zur Hölle werden die denn produziert? Weil wie kriegst du Flüssigkeit in die Schokolade rein? Wie geht das? Und jetzt stellst du die richtigen Frage. Sind die so seitlich wie so Reagenzgläser und dann kommt die Flüssigkeit
rein und dann ist da so ein Deckel drauf? Warum gibt es da keine Verschwörungstheorien eigentlich? Ja, unsere Politiker sind Eidechsen, aber die richtigen Fragen stellten niemand. Ja, was sind Erfrischungsstäbchen? Ist George Bush nicht eigentlich ein Erfrischungsstäbchen? Das sind die Fragen, die erfrischend sind. Und warum gehören Bill Gates 90 Prozent an Juffer Cakes? Hä? Das stimmt. Warum gehört den Rothschilds alle Erfrischungsstäbchen-Fabriken in ganz Europa? Als einzige Fabrik. Warum? Nee, im Ernst, warum kann man nicht mal die Frage stellen? Warum? Weißt du, was ich gerne von innen sehen würde? Fabriken, die Yu-Gi-Oh!-Karten oder Pokémon-Karten oder Magic-Karten herstellen.
Weil, wie läuft das ab, diese
Booster-Packs zu packen,
dass die so, wie randomized sind die?
Wie randomized sind die?
Ist das eine große Lüge?
Ist das eine große Trading-Kart-Lüge?
Gibt es manche Karten vielleicht super
selten? Schwierig.
Schwierig. Ich weiss nur, dass du so
große Sheets hast. Du hast so große,
riesige Sheets, wo einmal jede
Karten selten drauf ist, weil manche Magic-Sammler
Vielen Dank. Selten? Schwierig. Schwierig. Ich weiß nur, dass du so grosse Sheets hast. Du hast so grosse riesige Sheets, wo einmal jede Kartenseltenheit drauf ist, weil manche Magic-Sammler haben auch diese Sheets, die haben nicht die einzelnen Karten, sondern haben so einen ganzen Sheets an der Wand, die Ungestanzten an der Wand gehängt. Und manchmal gibt es auch Sachen, dabei ist da nur eine Karte drauf. Ne, ne, ganz viele Karten. Tatsächlich verschiedene Karten. Wie viele? Naja, vielleicht so 10 mal 20 oder 20 mal 10. Okay, also entweder 200 oder 200. Genau, ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber irgendwo zwischen diesen zwei Zahlen müsste ich. Okay, das ist eine Menge Karten. Das sind alle Karten, die in diesem Boosterpack vorkommen. Nee, das weiß ich nicht. Da hört dein Wissen schon auf. Da bin ich ich, wirklich, mein Wissen ist max sehr begrenzt. Wie viele Karten, glaubst du, sind in so einem Yu-Gi-Oh! Booster-Pack tendenziell zu haben? Möglicherweise. Ja, also, bei Magic sind die Sets ungefähr so 300 Karten gross. Und du kaufst dir Boosters von einem Set, gewissen Set, und da sind dann von den 300 dann keine 11 oder 15, je nachdem wie es läuft drin.
Okay, ich verstehe nicht, wie man das herstellen soll, weil du willst ja
Druckkosten sparen, denke ich mir auch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die so weit
denken, aber du willst ja
Druckkosten sparen, weil da machen die
auch sehr viel, weil du musst ja dann
ein, es reicht ja nicht
ein Sheet, also eine Druckvorlage,
die brauchen ja viel mehr, weil manche Karten
sind ja seltener als
1 zu 300. Ja, die sind häufiger auf dem Sheet drin,
Das ist ein Glurak. in den Topf werfen und dann elf rausziehen. Das heißt, eigentlich könnte man sich ja vor die Fabrik stellen und weiß,
oh, in jedem hundertsten Booster, das diese Fabrik verlässt, ist ein Glurak drin.
Und dann halt so
zack, zack,
sich immer die rausschnappen.
Könnte sein, es kann sein, dass es Leute gibt, die das machen.
Und mit so einem langen, mit so einem
Müllgreifer vor der Fabrik stehen
und da vom Fließband, durchs Fenster
jedes hundertste Boosterpack rausstehen.
Auch hier Pech schwarzer Qualm.
Ja, wirklich.
Der aus der Fabrik.
Großer grüner Schleimtropf aus so einem Rohr raus.
So glänzend, neongrün.
Ja, neongrüner glänzender Schleim.
Und ab und zu macht so und dann kommt so eine Flamme wie so Ölraffinerien, kommen so aus der Fabrik raus und man denkt sich, was passiert hier? Ja. Was geschieht hier? Ja. Erz, Eisenerz, nein, Pokémon-Karten werden hier hergestellt. Ach, herrlich. Fabriken finde ich spannend. Fabriken finde ich richtig spannend. Habt ihr eine Fabrik da draußen? Ja, habt ihr eine Fabrik? Und oder seid Segellehrer. Dann meldet euch bei diesem Podcast. Also, seid ihr bei Tele5 oder RTL-Info, seid ihr in der Knetindustrie zu haben, habt ihr eine Tochter, die Steffi heißt, die wir borgen können, um einfach mal diverse Industrien zu revolutionieren, habt ihr eine Yo-Gi-Oh!-Karten-Fabrik oder habt ihr eine Twix-Fabrik oder irgendwas in der Richtung?
Oder seid Segellehrer.
Oder seid ihr Segellehrer.
Mittlerweile einfach, eigentlich kann jeder schreiben.
Schreibt uns.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir euch irgendwie brauchen können,
ist sehr, sehr hoch. Und wir euch spannend finden, ist generell
schon mal bei 100%.
Schreibt uns einfach, wir finden schon für euch
Verwendung, wir werden schon irgendwas inkriegen.
Freut euch übrigens, die Vorbereitung zu dem grossen Giftfestival, Laufen auf Hochtouren. Also da wird im Hintergrund sehr viel gearbeitet und viel in Bewegung gesetzt, da werden ganze Menschenmassen Berge versetzt, um euch eine fantastische Preisverlagung zu präsentieren. Auf Instagram wird das stattfinden, wir haben ganz, ganz viele tolle Gifs bekommen, viele mittelmäßige, reichlich schlechte Gifs. Leute haben uns schon bestehende Gifs einfach geschickt. Das ist nicht die Idee. Ihr müsst die schon selber machen. Du kannst nicht ... Dieses Einschicken hat irgendwie ... Haben wir da die Kontrolle verloren. Komplett. Du kannst nicht beim Cannes Filmfestival irgendwie Leon der Profi einschicken. Das geht nicht. Also, ich würde gerne einreichen, Argo. Okay. Hier haben sie die. Wollt mal, Argo mit Ben Affleck? Hier haben sie die DVD. Und die DVD fehlt. Warum legen sie uns? Ah, die ist noch im Laufwerk. Nein, die ist noch im... Warten Sie, warten Sie kurz, ich fahre kurz nach Hause. So ein Fahrrad. Klingling! Aus dem Weg, aus dem Weg, so an den ganzen Limousinen vorbei. Argo, es fehlt Argo gegen den Verkehrsstrom. Aus dem Weg, Argo, Argo! Und er war nie wieder gesehen. Und Argo hat dieses Jahr nicht so viel Preis gemacht. Und deswegen hat Argo nicht 2021 kann. Die Neuverfilmung? Nein. Nein, der mit Ben Affleck. Ach so, ist ein guter Film. Ja, Mensch, gib ihm doch mal einen Preis. Ja, das finde ich albern, dass ihr jetzt Nine-Cat eingereicht habt. Hast du die Oscar-Verlagung mitverfolgt, oder war dir das wirklich vollkommen egal?
Mir ist es komplett an mir vorbeigegangen. Völliges Desinteresse. Selbst aber den Schauspielern ist es doch auch egal. Ich glaube, denen ist es wirklich egal. Stell dir mal vor, du gewinnst in einem Jahr, wo das so eine B-Veranstaltung war, wo die meisten das vergessen haben, wo selbst einige Veranstalter das vergessen haben. Ist aber auch tragisch, ne, irgendwie seit zehn Jahren schreibstreibst du da ein Drehbuch irgendwie von wegen der Geschichte von Paule mit Reinkarnation, irgendwie aktueller Anlass und so. Ja, Patschenlamer. Film kommt raus, du gewinnst den Oscar und alle so, ach, die gibt's noch? Das hat stattgefunden? Also, die ist ja stattgefunden? Natürlich hat es stattgefunden. Die Konkurrenz war wahnsinnig krass. Ich habe da gewonnen gegen Filme von etablierten Hollywood-Regisseuren, die seit Jahren im Business sind und ich als Newcomer habe gewonnen. Herrgott, ich habe gegen Argo gewonnen. Und dann ist der Preis immer noch der goldene Oscar. Ja, natürlich ist es der goldene Oscar. Was glaubst du denn? Es ist immer noch die Oscar-Verleihung. Ach so, ja, weil ich dachte, dass es mittlerweile so Urkunden gibt. Es gab auch eine Urkunde, aber es gab, nein, es gab, ja, aber das ist nur formell. In der Zeremonie habe ich die Statuette bekommen, den goldenen Oscar. Den, den man kennt? Ja, den man kennt. Ich habe einen Oscar gewonnen. Willst du jetzt was essen oder nicht? Ja. Willst du es mitbestellen? Ja, ich nehme Galiknan, drei, Trippelnan. Ein Garliknan ist zu wenig Garliknan. Viel zu wenig. Nan tatsächlich, ich gebe es zu, habe ich letztes Mal versucht, selber zu machen. Habe ich auch schon häufig selber gemacht. Aber schwer, ist schwer. Ich habe es zweimal gemacht, es ist mir beides mal unglaublich gut gelungen. Es ist super schwer, richtig hinzukriegen. Ich behaupte, es ist mir besser gelungen, als bei dem Inder, bei dem ich immer bestelle. Weil die haben ja diese geilen Öfen, die so, die absolut verrückte Öfen sind, Tandori-Ofen. Ich erkläre dir kurz, wie ein Tandori-Ofen funktioniert. Du hast ein Feuer und darüber einfach so ein ja, ein Gefäss, das oben offen ist und du legst die Naan, also Naan ist ja dieses indische Brot, dieses Fladenbrot, das legst du nicht übers Feuer, sondern klatscht du so an die Innenseite dieses Gefäßes. Und wenn es runterfällt, ist es fertig. Dann ist es fertig. Wenn es in die Kohlen fällt, ins Feuer fällt, dann ist es fertig. Wenn es verbrannt ist, ist es fertig. Okay, ja. Und es klatscht so an die Seite und es haftet da und dadurch wird es einerseits dadurch, dass das Gefäß heiß ist, gebacken, aber auch durch die heiße Luft. Toll, hat man zu Hause natürlich nicht. Nee, ich mache es in der Pfanne und es funktioniert sehr gut. Wo hast du es drin gemacht? Ich habe auch in der Pfanne gemacht, aber in manchen Tutorials muss man es sogar in der Pfanne klebend über die offene Flamme halten. So, jetzt reicht es. Wenn du ein Gas herzt hast. Jetzt reicht es. Es reicht. Das ist so experimentell. Nee, bei mir sind die wirklich fantastisch geworden beide mal. Ich musste beides mal laut lachen, weil es so gut geworden ist, in der Pfanne. Das heißt, du saßt alleine zu Hause bei dir. Nee, es waren ganz viele, ganz, ganz, ganz viele Freunde da. Und hast dir schön ein paar Nans gebraten und hast laut gelacht, als du sie gegessen hast, während alle anderen ein bisschen bedröppelt waren. Ja, alle anderen wussten nicht, was los ist. Wir essen nur Naan? Ich dachte, das ist nur eine Beilage. Wir bestellen das sonst immer nur als Beilage. Es ist perfekt. Es gibt nur Naan? Alle saßen also sehr niedergeschlagen. Mir reicht Naan. Ich wünsche euch eine fantastische Woche.
Herrliche Woche, habt eine schöne Woche.
Kommt gut rein in die nächste Woche.
Kommt gut rein in den nächsten Monat und nehmt auch schon mal Anlauf fürs nächste Jahr. Es kann nie zu früh sein.
Nee, wenn ihr jetzt schon mal die Silvesterparty plant, dann habt ihr sicher eine Feier, wo ihr dabei seid.
Und Silvester ist immer, jeder kennt das, man schiebt es vor sich her.
Ja, das ganze Jahr.
Macht das dieses Jahr mal nicht.
Einfach mal Silvester im Mai angehen.
Es lohnt sich, habt eine schöne Woche, haut rein, wir verabschieden uns und schießen in die Höhe. Auch ab.
Ciao.